what is the darkest place you ever gone
in your mind
do you is there a time a period of time
a moment
that you remember that was difficult for
you mean when i was 18 my best friend
died of a heroin overdose
and
it was like my
it was it and then shortly after that
one of my other best friends committed
suicide
um
and that
sort of like coming into adulthood
dealing with two of the most important
people in my life dying in extremely
disturbing violent ways was
a lot that was a lot do you miss them
yeah definitely miss them did that make
you think about your own life
about the finiteness of your own life
the the the the places your mind can go
did you ever
in the distance far away contemplate
um
just your own death
or maybe even taking your own life no
never oh no no i'm so
i love my life
i cannot fathom suicide i'm so scared of
death i haven't i'm too scared of death
my manager my my manager is like the
most zen guy my manager's always like
you need to accept death you need to
accept death and i'm like look i can do
your meditation i can do the meditation
but i cannot accept death i like
yeah
of death i will like fight
although i actually think death is
import important i recently went to this
um
uh meeting about immortality um and in
the process of that's the actual topic
of the meeting all right no no it was it
was this girl it was a bunch of people
working on like anti-aging like um
stuff it was like some like seminary
thing about about it and i went in
really excited i was like yeah like okay
like what do you got like how can i live
for 500 years or a thousand years and
then like over the course of the meeting
like it was sort of like right it was
like two or three days after the russian
invasion started and i was like man like
what if putin was immortal
like
what if i i'm like man maybe or
immortality
is not good i mean like if you get into
the later dunes stuff the immortals
caused a lot of problem because as we
were talking about earlier with the
music and like brains calcified like
good people could become immortal but
bad people could become immortal but i
also think
even the best people
power corrupts and power alienates you
from like the common human experience
and right so the people that get more
and more powerful even the best even the
best people who like whose brains are
amazing like i i think death might be
important i think death is part of
you know like i i think with ai one
thing we might want to consider
i don't know i want to talk about ai i'm
such not an expert and probably everyone
has all these ideas and they're already
figured out but whenever he is an expert
in anything see okay go ahead but when
i'm talking about it yeah but i like
it's just like
i think some kind of pr pruning
it's a tricky thing because because if
there's too much of a of a focus on
youth culture
then you don't have the wisdom
so i feel like we're in a tricky
we're in a tricky moment right now in
society where it's like we've really
perfected living for a long time so
there's all these really like old people
who are like
really voting against
the well-being of the young people
you know and like like
it's like there shouldn't be all this
student debt and we need like health
care like universal health care and like
like just voting against like
best interests but then you have all
these young people that don't have the
wisdom that are like like yeah we need
communism and stuff and it's just like
like literally i got canceled at one
point for um
i ironically used a stalin quote in my
high school yearbook but it was actually
like a
a diss against my high school i saw that
yeah and and people were like you used
to be a stalinist and now you're a class
trader and it's like
it's like oh man just like please google
stalin yeah please google stalin like
you ignoring his the lessons of history
yes
and it's like we're in this really weird
middle ground where it's like
we are not finding the happy medium
between miz wisdom
and fresh ideas and they're fighting
each other and it's like
like really
like what we need is like like the fresh
ideas and the wisdom to be like
collaborating and it's like
well the fighting in in a way is the
searching for the happy medium and in a
way maybe we are finding the happy
medium that maybe that's what the happy
medium looks like and for ai systems
there has to be it's you know you have
the reinforcement learning you have the
dance between exploration exploitation
sort of doing crazy stuff to see if
there's something better than what you
think is the optimal and then doing the
optimal thing and dancing back and forth
from that you would um stewart russell
enough you know that is um
ai guy with um thinks about sort of how
to control super intelligent ai systems
and his ideas that we should inject
uncertainty and sort of humility into ai
systems that they never as they get
wiser wise they're wiser more
intelligent they're never really sure
they always doubt themselves and
in some sense when you think of young
people that's a mechanism for doubt
it's like it's it's how society doubts
whether the thing it has converged
towards is the right answer so the the
voices of the young people
is a society asking itself a question
the way i've been doing stuff for the
past 50 years maybe it's the wrong way
and so you can have all of that within
one ai system i also think though that
we need to i mean actually that's
actually interesting and really cool um
but i also think there's a fine balance
of
i think we maybe also overvalue
the idea that the old systems are always
bad and i think there are things that we
are perfecting and we might be
accidentally overthrowing things that we
actually have gotten to a good point
yeah just because we are valuing we
value disruption so much and we value
fighting against the generations before
us so much
that like
there's also an aspect of like sometimes
we're taking two steps forward one step
back because okay
we maybe we kind of did solve this thing
and now we're like [ __ ] it up
you know and and and so i think there's
like
a middle ground there
you